faresti del male a questa creaturina ti
rende noto che c'è gente che abbandoni
cani di un'altra vacanze che a me ma
come fanno a chi non piace questa razza
questo soggettivo e oggettivo che
abbiamo fatto una scoperta a siffatti
vorrei un attimo fermare questo momento
innanzitutto benvenuti e lavorava la
nuova giornata
vieni con me non crescerà mai nulla
ultime parole famose
stai già sbagliando tutto la donna bella
è la luce della ragione assisi ragazzi e
quei belen si vede mi sembra una sacca
di stipulare coppie che schifo da camera
anche sotto le macchine da vari
lavorando altra cosa deve prendere le
misure delle gomme della macchina perché
a breve partiremo per passare il natale
in sicilia e quindi dobbiamo prendere
cadere perché l'autostrada rischia di
essere anche con la neve alle 6 c'è la
finale di supercoppa italiana
faremo in viaggio immagino alle 6
assolutamente sì allora non guiderò in
quella fascia oraria permesso garantito
neanche io guido per fortuna allora deve
andare a prendere le misure della gomma
poi che a dobbiamo fare mangiare si va
beh iniziamo a fare qualcosa che fanno
il problema nation la cenerentola
frasca ne abbiamo bisogno le gomme
considera
ci sono 23 i cani lei adesso è lui che
ti sta portando va dove c'è la macchina
è rinviato a questa ruota 61 cm anni di
cristo per 255 che ci vuole no
gli anni di visto più d'uno una ventina
di centimetri di cristo meno 13 e che
c'è del metodo in questa cosa è male di
fare per quattro ruote non sono tutte
uguali e nike e c'è una di esse quelle
dietro 61 ruote profonda 8 cm 61 20 8
non subito alla ricerca delle catene 61
20 8 il cadenas dei nieve textiles non è
ma già comprato e scusa ma in spagna
hanno la rete velocità massima 50
chilometri l'ora
mamma non arrivarono ho appena scoperto
l'errore deve andare a vedere la marca
delle gomme e qui mi dice
automaticamente che gomma devo metterci
e quindi dobbiamo scegliere se ci
mettono dunque al cane
[Musica]
195 55 r16 cioè dove che ci sei andato
fatto lettrice stracciato lasciamo stare
più 62
100.5 55 r16 non ce l'ho qui stampata
che sono dimenticati cerri centola è un
po sporco vedo vestiti pensare al cane
non parlare più così
185 55 r16 lemme divertente dialogo che
cercare vuote o un uomo in equilibrio
sull'ottava andiamo per il culo ma tu
hai già pensato oltre al secret il
regalo per luigi i regali per luigi
perché molto iniziavano a molto perché
c'è natale e il compleanno che il 30
dicembre poi il vg è difficile mamma mia
the nella come si dice dopo ci fermiamo
a mangiare si può fare se io posso
dimenticare di dover pensare al regalo a
uno specchio gianmarco
lo sono ideali ma visto che arrivavano
fisici a destra mentre guardavo i cavoli
miei stop
ecco sono divulgate
conte che prendere lui
bianco santo preso
enrico sai cosa un giorno 21 dove cosa
non sosta e di crude
ma cosa che dico non sopporta questa
cosa
avete visto il miscuglio non lo tollero
da vedere come sapete chi prende la
gente già prima della maionese perché
una salsa più solida rispetto alla parte
più quindi quando ne va a capovolgere
non casca e dall'altro verso 5 nella
barbie è una roba da pazzi gente non
immetti dagli inizi perché sennò
contamini le salse se tu vuoi il soul
bar ma io non mai e poi mai in solo
parco e questo romanese no direi di far
sapere dalla gente team enrico team
miscuglio acune ridotti gianmarco
giometti merigo e specifico il mio in
una ragazzata chimerico team gianmarco
dove si è mangiato tutto che si è
bagnato è nello stesso esercizio
supplementare e alla fine l'ha bagnata
non è vero non è sul mare giammarco
chiaramente di indecisione per la
maggiore comunque dire che vede così
durano tutto io sto ancora fino al mio
famiglie che non sia in maniera diretta
la vera domanda è chi è che ha alzato il
proprio scudo al setto scudo fiera e
piante non puoi entrare nel mio esercito
del 300
perché disonorevole e mangiarlo nel
finita ma la sai la storia o 300 milioni
da dice alza il tuo sito
evento che gli altri non riesce ad
alzare lo scudo e quindi è la stessa
quella parola sia fine pasto a riti
chiaroscuro pesante
non sei uno spartano fatto sta che non
ne sono più scuse
vorrei dire una cosa che mi la ragazza
che ci ha servito molto gentilmente alla
fine è uscita fuori mentre stavo andando
alla macchina per dirci scusate ragazzi
si è infortunato in realtà è stata
gentilissima ci ha detto dove si dirci
ci ha portato le cose al tavolo stata
quindi super carina e l'ho detto no no
tranquillo non problema l'ha detto non
sai private ti vedo qui enrico ruvido
sempre ma perché si sa che sono
lavoratori con una memoria una memoria
ferrea no tutto qua sono sicuro che
questo è motivo emily possiamo pure dire
tanto che la vedrà in stasera abbiamo
detto para tanti auguri di natale non ci
vediamo prima verrico delle parate un
giorno sì el'altro pure cosa è stato
fregato e lui mi faceva 11 è stato
regalato ri come mangio posso
assicurarvi che il cisl ha mangiato
guglielmo commentate scrivendo enrico
mac mangio e tutte alte frasi che si
possono fare con enrico mac e commentato
iscrivendo cheeseburger oppure abbiamo
il rigo che preferisce la tradizione
italiana enrico [ __ ]
in questi casi ci servirebbe lo zio che
esca il prima di al posto una smart che
si è [ __ ] un posto per 12 persone
uscirà qualcuno ti odio uscirà qualcuno
uscirà qualcuno così fai vomitare la
gente ma era ritmo melodico anche a
capire anche lo sfratto invece sarà
ci ho messo tre ore per cercare girare
in tondo e mi devi fare il clacson
perché devi muoverti a sei andata lei si
chiama parcheggiata sempre ieri nel
torto adattare persone non hanno più
tempo di aspettare e fare bisognerebbe
tutti quanti fare un bel sorriso e
infilarsi qualcosa nel culo col sorriso
da 20 minuti giro qui uscirà a qualcuno
stiamo facendo un blog sul pareggio e
poi oggi facciamo una cosa
importantissima stiamo per dire una cosa
molto segreta uscirà qualcuno uscirà
qualcuno uscirà qualcuno riuscirà
qualcuno sia qualcuno parcheggio
un posto che ci sfuggirà dei soldi
guarda ma la mia legge dell'attrazione
non vuole che io faccia sempre il solito
va tutto alla grande televisione
poi dopo la rivista ho trovato delle tue
foto fluid warriors of freedom
sbam guglielmo bacci del mio natale
anticipato e quindi adesso lo devo ad
aprire era cosmetics c'è una free cose
un cucchiaio un cucchiaio che ci ammazza
mi chiedo ma chi ha una scatola di
trucchi e acid è infatti un tonico molto
meno peggio di prima
miser
aspetta quindi che cos'altro purissima
meno che un altro perfetto alla linea ti
sta rubando il burro no lo sto prendendo
momentaneamente lucia che sarà aprire
qui la mamma mia si sa benissimo che io
avevo collego è chiuso che futuro aperto
c'è ancora scritto chiusura che l'ha
detto la forza potente tornata è ora
tutta tua abilitato mostra e vede
nessuna regola accesso è una cosa a
ricordare chiudevi davis imparare ciò
che ha imparato che fanno male a
creazione con treedom che ci ha già
puntato come seriali luigi ama scrivere
mi rendono se il paziente del tavolino
godiamo inizierà che abbiamo insieme è
una mia amica ragazzo e una ragazza che
sta su youtube
sfuma anche un po per la linea davvero
grandi schermi gremi allora qui abbiamo
inspire da ieri lettere indebitato veli
ma abbiamo estetico book un look che amo
perché c'ha i vini mazza che canteranno
sono belle attacco al tatto sabellini
dialettico rubrica il tracker degli
eventi stupendo jacob rilascio pure il
link qua sotto comunque ragazze alla
fine del video dell'altro ieri c'è stato
un piccolo così passaggio di un qualcosa
da quest'anno lavorando dopo una scritta
prossimamente
e arrivato il momento di dichiarare che
cosa stiamo facendo
dico non verrà con diventare andiamo
stiamo andando a fare una cosa che se
tagliatissimo meglio così che lo è fermo
almeno da fare una cosa un po folle che
ha organizzato gianmarco o alle nostre
spalle che è una canzone stavo andando a
incidere una canzone ho tanta paura
tanta paura e un bel titolo questo amico
di gianmarco che si chiama marco marcob
lardino marcob lardino esatto è un è un
produce musicale ha studiato tanti anni
dove a berlino a berlino e ha deciso di
farsi a fare questa cosa
insieme a noi non la fa brutta figura
guarda ai fatto cinema radio teatro
video in generale che altre tutto cagare
di manca una canzone un attimo
riscaldare la voce mi hanno affidato gli
artisti non fare anche cose di qua credo
che siano un altro tipo di arte ma con
te se avete solo il mento e lo so posso
diventare gobbo si inizia a fare un
rebus
ora voglio che ci sia cece mento adempì
eccoci qui discografia italiana presto
per marco non ha parlato qui abbiamo la
meravigliosa strumento alla gente con la
quale marco daremo la la calzatura 5
reti arrivano vicino pensateci signorini
sono fra i soci sono un po questi giorni
ho tirato giù un testo che vediamo a più
libera sostanzialmente cercando di
parlare dal punto di vista quindi ho
cercato di prendere diciamo delle cose
che parlano di te e poi da vedere
insieme perché koch e ultimo la scuola
può che non fanno vedere io conosco dal
diritto
andrea assolutamente con questa roma
per ogni italiano posso dire però la mia
amica www.make
un'auto
marco l'uomo beppe vessicchio il reato è
molto più divertenti di cotto non
pensassi detto questo se non esce fuori
una cosa carinissima troppo troppo
carina mi ha fatto troppo e troppo
carina aggiungere un'altra
[Musica]
allora abbiamo finito questa giornata di
chiacchiere che c'è che gianmarco le
cose fatte queste rotonde mi confondo
four indicando verso questo è come
cinzia chissà dove devo andare la stava
accompagnando lo fa così è appena
sbaglio l'uscita mi fa così piano piano
indicandolo il city riuscire a chiudere
un secondo questo momento però fate un
po di chiacchiere e ho buttato giù un
pochino di idee
domani ritorniamo a lavorare quindi
praticamente ci vedremo direttamente
domani